that night Hong Kong was burning this
Asian commercial hub one of the busiest
commercial cities in the world was on
fire and the police seemed completely
unable to stop it this has been a tactic
they've moved around the demonstrators
they something quickly and then move to
a different area it's quite difficult to
believe what master the understatement
extremely difficult to be one of the key
turning points in this whole protracted
tussle between the Hong Kong authorities
and the protesters for me was the arrest
of key political activists on the eve of
a mass planned rally seeing the site of
Joshua Wong and Agnes Chau behind police
van bars on the eve of a mass rally
I think incensed the protesters and the
demonstrators they saw this as a very
definite attempt at intimidation a very
definite attempt to try to stop the
protesters coming out and even though
the authorities banned the rally they
turned out in their thousands the arrest
of the the political activists almost
seemed to incensed them even more seem
to make them more determined to get out
and once they'd showed that there was
perfect capability of having a peaceful
gathering it didn't take long before it
descended into violence if they
surprised us more will resist
and if they're trying to cure with
ribbons just let us burn together it's
not sure who started this but there is
very much a feeling amongst the
protesters and demonstrators that they
are fighting for their rights and the
authorities are trying to suppress them
within a few hours
there was a spray of teargas being fired
I've never seen so much tear gas being
fired at one event the demonstrators
reacted by throwing many petrol bombs
some had clearly come gathered with
rocks they used slingshots to fire
marbles back
they threw back the gas canisters they
threw back the the tear gas bombs back
at the police the crowd moved around the
different streets and alleyways right in
the center of this commercial hub with
onlookers tourists travelers
businesspeople looking on
they built barricades they set fire to
to these barricades and the whole of the
evening seemed to be in the control of
these hundreds of protesters who were
leading the riot police a real dance
around the streets of Hong Kong the
police responded with great violence
storming into subway stations trying to
arrest people who they said were
protesters who changed out of their
their riot gear and were trying to blend
in with normal civilians the storming of
the police into subway trains absolutely
terrified many of the the ordinary
civilians who were cowering with their
families watching these aggressive riot
police and when I saw one riot police
who they can look very intimidating in
all their
gear and armed with weapons going up to
a member of the Hong Kong media who did
not seem to fit the profile of any of
the demonstrators I felt it was an
attempt again to intimidate the media
because they're feeling very anxious
about this image that is yes or no are
you getting control of the streets and
having him turn on me like I I could see
why they're so intimidated because he
was very angry and he was obviously very
tense about being questioned oh my
goodness look at the state of that stick
that those demonstrators are holding
careful there's coming down Toby pull to
the side if people thought it was all
over they were badly mistaken this time
they were marching on the International
Airport they turned up in huge numbers
and even if many did not get inside the
terminal they managed to build layers of
barricades around the perimeter of the
airport buildings and basically jammed
up and gridlocked all the routes leading
to the airport
the protesters seemed to be getting more
and more frustrated and more and more
angry they moved quickly into the nearby
town the nearest town to the airport
tung chung and they stormed the subway
station there they broke open the fire
extinguisher and flooded the whole
station they even managed to attack the
control room things have really taken a
turn for the worse that serious amount
of destruction look at the terminals
getting into the train station they
flooded the area with water they broke
into a
a fire extinguisher and they've trashed
everything and what is extraordinary as
someone who's witnessing all this is the
level of support all these young people
have despite the vandalism despite the
inconvenience despite the destruction
there's still a really high degree of
support for what these people are
fighting for
even we worry about our job that we will
stand here to tell them we are not easy
to give up